Muy buenas tardes efectivamente la final
de este domingo será entonces entre
Novak Djokovic y Casper Rut puede haber
un poco de sorpresa ahí o tal vez como
de tristeza para los afáns de Carlos
Alcaraz en un partidazo que jugó hoy
ante nueva Djokovic especialmente
Durante los dos primeros sets porque
luego el acuerdo del español lo dejó
dejamos se llenó de calambres al
comienzo de ese tercer set y ya después
para el español era prácticamente
imposible pegarle alguna pelota de
volver alguna pelota y terminó perdiendo
este partido en cuatro sets más de tres
horas de juego él dijo que había entrado
muy con muchísima atención a jugar este
partido y que eso le había jugado una
mala pasada falta de experiencia y la
experiencia que si tiene Novak Djokovic
que entonces va a disputar su séptima
final de Roland garros pero sobre todo
que va a por ese título número 23 de
Gran slam para convertirse en el jugador
pues que más a títulos de estos tiene Y
por supuesto va a medirse
Alexander el Alemán que parece que nunca
entró partido ganando seis tres seis
cuatro seis cero por parte de Ruth un
tenis son muy sólido es lo que ha venido
mostrando Y aprovechando también una
parte baja del tablero que finalmente le
permitió seguir sobre todo después de
que saliera eliminado Daniel el número
dos de mundo y ahora pues vuelve por
segundo año consecutivo a la final de
Roland garros pero hombre no le no va a
ser fácil el año pasado le tocó contra
Rafael Nadal y este año será contra Así
que muchas expectativas frente a esta
final que viviremos este próximo domingo